what i want to do in this video is give
you a bunch of properties of limits and
we're not going to prove it rigorously
here in order to have the rigorous proof
of these properties we need a rigorous
definition of what a limit is and we're
not doing that in this tutorial we'll do
that in the tutorial on the epsilon
delta definition of limits but most of
these should be fairly intuitive and
they're very helpful for simplifying
limit problems in the future
so let's say we know that the limit of
some function f of x as x approaches c
is equal to capital l and let's say that
we also know
that the limit of some other function
let's say g of x as x approaches c is
equal to capital m
now given that what would be the limit
of f of x plus g of x
as
x
approaches c
well and you could look at this visually
if you look at the graphs of two
arbitrary functions you essentially just
add those two functions it'll be pretty
clear that this is going to be equal to
and once again i'm not doing a rigorous
proof i'm just really giving you the
properties here this is going to be the
limit of f of x as x approaches c plus
the limit
of g of x as x approaches c which is
equal to
well this right over here is let me do
that in that same color
this
right here is just equal to l it's going
to be equal to l plus
l plus
m this right over here is equal to m
not too difficult this is often called
the sum
the sum rule or the sum property of
limits and we could come up with a very
similar one with differences the limit
as x approaches c of
f of x
minus g of x is just going to be
l minus m it's just the limit of f of x
as x approaches c minus the limit of g
of x as x approaches c
so it's just going to be l
minus
l
minus m
that's often called the difference rule
or the difference property of limits and
these once again are very very hopefully
some reasonably intuitive
now what happens if you take the product
of the functions the limit of f of x
times
g of x
as
x approaches c
well lucky for us this is going to be
equal to the limit
of f of x as x approaches c
times the limit
of g of x as x approaches c lucky for us
this is kind of a fairly intuitive
property of limits so in this case this
is going to be equal to
this is l
times m
l times this is just going to be l
same thing if we instead of having a
function here we had a constant
so if we just had the limit let me do
that same color
the limit
of
k times f of x
as x approaches c where k is just some
constant this is going to be the same
thing as k times the limit of f of x
as x approaches c and that is just equal
to
this is just equal to l
this is equal to l so this whole thing
simplifies to k
times
k times l
and we can do the same thing with
difference this is often called the
constant multiple property we can do the
same thing with differences
so if we have the limit
as x approaches c of f of x divided by g
of x this is the exact same thing as the
limit of f of x as x approaches c
divided by the limit of g of x
as x approaches c which is going to be
equal to i think you get it now this is
going to be equal to l
over m
over
m
and finally this is sometimes called the
quotient property finally we'll look at
the exponent property so if i have
if i have the limit
of
let me write it this way of f of x to
some power and actually let me write
even write it as a fractional power to
the r over s power where both r and s
are integers then the limit of f of x to
the r over s power as x
approaches
c
is going to be the exact same thing as
the limit of f of x
as x approaches c
raised to the r over s power once again
when r and s are both integers and s is
not equal to zero otherwise this
exponent would not make much sense and
this is the same thing this is the same
thing as l
this is the same thing as l to the r
over s powers this is equal to l
to the
l to the
r
over s power so using these we can
actually find the limit of many many
many things and it's what's neat about
it is the properties of limits kind of
are the things that you would naturally
want to do and if you graph some of
these functions actually turns out to be
quite intuitive